[Music]
at 5 45 a.m a woman named maya
wakes up in a new unfamiliar city today
is her first day at a new job
after having recently moved at 7 20 a.m
she waits at the train station nearest
her apartment at 5
28 pm she will take the same train again
home
this first morning she gets on the last
car at the back of the train
every day at 5 34 pm a man named reeve
takes the same train to work for his
night shift
then again at 7 25 am he takes it home
reeve always rides in the last train car
preferring the back for reasons he's
never really thought about
today like every other day he sits in
the back left section of the left corner
today unlike any other day maya enters
the train for the first time
and sits just a couple seats away in the
same section
as she does reeve notices her and then
quickly looks down to his phone
pretending that he hasn't
almost simultaneously just missing eye
contact maya notices reeve
as well also quickly looking the other
way both sit quietly on opposite corners
of the same section of the same car
of the same train as they glide through
a city of millions of other things and
people
both thinking only about the other at
this exact same moment
in time on her way home from work maya
gets on the rear train car again
and sits in the same relative section
several stops later like he always does
reeve does the same as he rounds the
corner of the train's doorway and moves
down the aisle
he meets eyes with maya in unison a
small subtle lip smile automatically
forms on each of their faces
immediately followed by a downward break
of eye contact in this moment
through some weird shared connection
affirmed by a soft contortion of the
face
an inexplicable sense of almost fate
fills each of their heads
barred off by nerves and the quirks of
interaction though neither wanting to
bother the other
and both fearing the strangeness of
rejection and failed attempts
they sit quietly secluded each screaming
in their heads
imagining notions of romance and lust
and futures that hurt a little less
as more days go by maya continues to get
on the same train car
on which continues to sit reeve each day
seems to almost exclusively contain
their brief exchange of smiles and nods
the days blurring together
only made truly lucid and worthwhile in
these introverted
yet potent acknowledgments of each other
eventually somewhere around the second
or third week of sharing the same train
schedule
a certain unusual confidence overtakes
reeve
on his way to work this day getting on
the 5 30 pm train following maya
he notices an open seat next to her for
the first time
he takes it after a brief pause and a
hidden explosion of nerves and
self-doubt
and an act of benign but heroic courage
he turns towards her
hi i'm reeve reeve meant to say but
actually said something that sounded
more like
hi reeve as a result of a small nervous
tick inflection of his voice
maya also nervous says wait who's reef
despite sort of realizing in real time
that reeve had mumbled what he meant to
say
i'm reeve reeve replies with a nervous
laugh unsure if maya is joking or not
oh hi my name i'm i'm maya
maya responds also with a sort of
nervous laugh and stammer of her words
this shared inability to speak
successfully somehow makes both a little
more comfortable with each other
the hello quickly turns into a
conversation about this and that
where they're going each day where
they're coming from and what they would
prefer those destinations were if it
were up to them
the conversation turns into more
conversations across more days
the two always sitting or standing next
to each other more conversations turn
into a series of dates
dates turn into a relationship a
relationship into love
a love neither have ever experienced
before a sort of love that horrible
unrealistic stories and movies peddle to
deny the dog from hell that it otherwise
normally is
the two fight and complain and clash
over all the usual topics and hitches of
relationships
but the love seems to pervade through it
all the desire to find solace in the
confusion of being
and non-being to fill in the missing
parts of self and purpose
to alleviate the strangeness and anxiety
of existing in the unknown they have
woken up to
all sustain the love even at the
relationship's worst
the world feels worthwhile in the clutch
of it
as far as one can be maya feels for the
first time in recent memory
like she is okay on one night reeve
takes maya wakes up disoriented and
almost scared
the feeling quickly goes away though as
she gets up gets ready
and leaves for work on her drive she
can't help but think about the dream she
had last night
and how it almost feels like an actual
memory of another life
her concerns of the oncoming day quickly
overtake and replace her thinking though
dissolving the dream setting and
characters into some oblivion that will
never be known
nor experienced nor remembered by anyone
including her
again maya works as an architectural
designer one for a mid to large size
design firm
she has recently started working at a
new firm after having left another
her main goal in life has and remains to
become an architectural project manager
developing and controlling the design
plans of buildings and city features
from the ground up for all intents and
purposes
she is passionately obsessed she has
given up relationships and left loves
unfounded
she has moved three times she has
sacrificed a great deal for it
but she can't imagine a life in which
she would be doing anything else
her work is her way of escaping the
uncertainty of everything else
the clarity and purpose and self-control
she finds in it
seems to make the chaos and confusion of
the world and her inexplicable place
within it
worthwhile today she is pitching several
new concepts for seating integrations
to potentially be applied to a large
restaurant redesign that the firm is
working on
after nerves and stress and an almost
blacking out of awareness
the pitch seems to go perfectly her
designs are brought onto the project
as more time seems to go by more and
more of maya's work is utilized and
developed into project plans
she is soon promoted to architectural
designer 2 the next higher rank-up at
the firm
not long after she is promoted to
designer three
eventually after a long stretch of time
that seems like almost no time at all
she is promoted to project manager her
teenage dream
now finally a reality as far as one can
maya feels okay like it has all been
worth it
her first two projects are a great
success both well received by the
clients
and highly regarded by the firm and
local industry at large
her concepts are a perfect balance of
being both simple yet innovative
subtle but effective her third project
is off to a great start as well
on track to be equally successful on one
of the build days
maya visits the construction site to
ensure that everything is in order
everything is off to a great start and
the day is like any and every other day
then for no explainable reason the
partly constructed building suddenly
collapses in on itself
the surface almost peeling back into a
collection of rubble and the rubble
seeming to almost disappear
or dissolve into the ground in a way
that should be impossible
sudden disorientation and horror
overtake maya terrified that she has
made
a horrible mistake then in nearly the
same instant
the other surrounding buildings and
homes within her view seem to also
simultaneously fall in a similar manner
peeling away from themselves and then
dissolving into the ground
maya begins to black out in a
disorientation as she hazily looks
around and notices the other workers
panicking
and frozen one by one they all appear to
peel off themselves and dissolve
the ground appears to begin the same
maya
now in a physically active panic quickly
tries a man named david reflects to
himself briefly as the software exits
out
the project file clears and the
experiment resets
he and two other researchers discuss the
experiment's results in a dark lab room
in front of them a large 180 degree
multi-screen monitor
connected to a state-of-the-art
supercomputer finishes its
reset and spews out a collection of data
results it's the second trial of the day
and the sixth of the week the results
have remained inconsistent with the
intended hypothesis
yet again rendering the experiment
mostly useless
david his two partners and a full team
of assistants are researching
consciousness
through a new highly controversial mind
modeling software
which maps and replicates the functions
of a brain in which
certain codes and commands can be
executed that simulate the electrical
activity of biological brain neurons
reproducing any mental and perceptual
state this then allows the software to
interact back and forth with an
artificially created exterior world
forming a hyper real comprehensive
imitation of human experience
and ordinary conscious phenomena
specifically in this experiment
david uses the software to set up a
character entity with baseline genetic
dispositions
false memories and influences of a
childhood and adult life
effects from altered states like dreams
and so on
the character is then sent through a
variety of scenes and moments of
decision making and performance
assessment
all for the purpose of testing david's
hypothesis of free will
in conscious like agents david who is
lead researcher and one of the staple
figures of the technology's development
has spent his whole life researching and
uncovering mysteries of the mind
he has been given several major grants
and awards over the span of his career
and is regarded as one of if not the
most important figure
of the 22nd century subsequently he is
one of six individuals who have been
given clearance to utilize the mind
modeling software
under a variety of strict guidelines
that limit the complexity nearly every
day
david constantly rediscovers the
childlike wonder that got him interested
in science and philosophy in the first
place
each needle pushed forward creating a
grander and more enthralling magic show
of reality david is 176 years old
he is of one of the last generations who
just missed a major transition
into substantial anti-aging technologies
just prior to
he was diagnosed with a late stage
irreversible brain cancer
one of the last to be diagnosed with any
form of cancer at all
of course it is only getting worse each
day and with mind uploading technologies
still not fully figured out
they're unlikely to catch up to him in
time with the reconciliation of free
will
randomness and determinism being one of
david's great remaining goals in life
he spends nearly all his time in pursuit
of this knowledge
after two more years of research at age
a series of simulations run consistent
with a set of david's predictions
confirming his hypothesis on this day
the truth of self-agency and free will
is discovered
as david looks down at the final test
results as far as one can
david feels like he is okay like it has
all
been worth it his greatest moment
achieved
after a series of successfully
reproduced experiments by other
scientists
david's theory is accepted by the
majority of the science and philosophy
community and not long after
by the public at large a few weeks later
david passes away from his cancer
following a series of complications
during a group of individuals watched
the digitally projected screen fade to
black
in the virtual reality theater they are
collected in it is the premiere of an
art exhibit by ray delar
delar a famous simulation artist codes
and creates complex worlds and stories
through autonomous characters coded with
artificial intelligence algorithms
all run on a simulation inside a massive
quantum supercomputer
in which the characters are sent through
simulated universes governed by sets of
laws that delar configures
anchoring and compelling the characters
to his intended storyline like a
marionettist with strings made of code
and a stage made of fabricated reality
as characters move through various maps
and scenes
the simulated world creates and deletes
parts of itself in real time
correlating with the characters
observations of it the simulation adds
environmental features consistent with
the character's imagined pasts
simultaneously encoding them with
confabulated false memories
making it seem like things are upwards
of billions of years old when in fact
everything is hours minutes seconds or
not at all each character contains a
fully simulated brain
with a simulated sense of self-awareness
and sensory inputs of a non-existent
physical
external universe delar is known and
renowned for his absurdly meta style
many of his characters are often coded
to doubt their realities
to suspect that something is off and to
become curious about what is
to consider that they are in something
or something is in them
to ask why where and how all for the
purposes of inciting story lines through
his character's attempts to solve
and deal with these uncertainties
through art and love and
self-improvement
and knowledge and the creation of other
realities
of course like all art dalar's work is a
product of his own fears anxieties
thoughts and theories he himself feels
what he gives many of his characters
a skepticism or doubt in reality a
feeling that his sense of what is real
is sufficiently detached from what
actually is he constantly wonders if he
is most likely just in someone or
something else's contrived reality
like his characters are in his if he is
living in a dream or simulation or a vat
of nutrient solution elsewhere
if some evil genius is in his head or if
the entire universe is in the head
of some evil genius delar doesn't feel
like any of this is true
but he also recognizes that he doesn't
know what any of these things feel like
he only knows what he feels like and he
feels like
everything could be anything his sense
of what feels real and natural
tells him that everything is real and
natural but what if what feels real and
natural
is nothing but a byproduct of the very
thing he fears is not
how can he trust what he feels without
having any way of knowing what he does
not
how can he know what exists outside his
head without ever being able to step
outside of it
and so he creates art to deal with this
confusion and anxiety and self-doubt
and to explore all possibilities he
creates worlds of other characters who
feel the same
after the screening ends as always
following a massive ovation
delar opens to a q a with the audience
several audience members ask about
coding techniques
his thoughts on the limitations of
current 23rd century computing power
the prospects of creating entirely
self-sustaining simulated worlds
concerns of ethics and so on the q a
goes as normal and is wrapping up
the last audience member in the line
approaches the mic to conclude the event
he asks the following hi this is
probably the
simplest question of the night but i'm
wondering your work seems to always
bring up questions of epistemology
obviously
doubts of actually having sufficient
knowledge of knowledge to know if we can
trust anything we think
you create worlds and people that think
and act and feel like they are just as
real as we think we are
but are of course not real in the way
they think they are at all but so my
question is
as a true skeptic you seem to doubt all
things but i'm curious have you ever
doubted
if any of that matters the audience
member pauses for a short moment
and then continues i mean love is felt
in the dreams of your character's
characters right
passions and purposes are had and made
in worlds within your worlds
apparent truths are discovered and
wonders are found in realities made of
no more than art and entertainment
if experiences are experienced in
anything anywhere
does it matter any less if it's real in
the way one thinks
and does it matter if one can or can't
prove it you show that knowing what is
real or not
is likely impossible that we all very
well could be inside some simulation
or a video or a story right now that we
could exist in some pre-coded
or deterministic system without any of
the free will that we yearn for
and feel like we have but does that
matter haven't you more revealed that
the uncertainty and unknowns of these
hows and whys and wheres and whats
is in fact a sustainable and desirable
quality that builds a potential infinity
of love
and desire and curiosity and isn't that
you exist somewhere
able to experience any of these things
all that you can truly know
and all that ultimately needs to matter
the audience member subtly nods his head
and steps back away from the mic to
imply the completion of his question
the virtual theater is quiet delar
pauses
and thinks for a moment then responds i
am
[Music]
do
you